Alright, Michael, I got a quiz for you, okay?
>> Sure.
>> So, in the last example we had noise free data.
So I want to think a little bit about what happens if we
have some noisy data. And so I'm going to come up with
a really weird, noisy model. But hopefully it illustrates the point. Okay.
>> Sure.
>> Okay so i got a bunch of training data, its x of i d
of i and here's how the true underline process sort of works. So give us some
particular x of i, you get a label which is
d of i which is equal to k times x of
i where k is some number So one of the
counting numbers, one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, and
so on and so forth. And the probability that you
actually get anyone of those multiples of x of i is
equal to one over two to the k. Now why did
I choose one over two to the k? Because it turns
out that the sum of all those two to the k's from one
through infinity happens to equal to
one. So it's a true probability distribution.
>> Hmm, okay.
>> So it's just a neat little geometric
distribution. So, you under understand the setup so far?
>> I think so, so before hypothesis were producing
answers then we looked for them to be exactly
in the data. Now we're saying that the hypothesis
produces an answer, and it gets kind of smooshed around
a little bit before it reappears in the table, thats the noisy part.
>> Right, so you, you're not going to be in a case now, that if
the hypothesis disagrees with the label it sees. That in fact that means no it
can't possibly be the right hypothesis because
there's some stochastic process going on that might
corrupt your output label, if you want to think
of it as corruption, since it's noisy. Okay?
>> Okay, yeah sure.
>> Alright?
>> Okay, so here's
a set of data that you got. Here's a bunch of x's that, that make
up our training data one, three, 11, 12,
and 20. For some reason they're in ascending
order. And the labels that go along with them are five, six, 11, 36, and 100. So
you'll notice that they're all multiples of some sort of the input x. Okay?
>> Alright.
>> Now I have a candidate hypothesis.
H of x which just returns x. That's kind of neat.
So it's the identity function. So, what I want you to do
is to compute the probability of seeing this particular data set in
a world where that hypothesis, the identity function, is in fact true.
>> The identity function plus this noise process.
>> Yes.
>> And one other question quickly this, this noise
process is supplied independently to each of these inputs,
outputs, pairs?
>> Yes, absolutely.
>> Okay, then, yeah, I think I can do that. Uh-huh.
>> Okay, go.